you won't believe this America the Biden
Administration is admitting that Donald
Trump is right we need the war and it
has to be built and we want to build it
fast we're going to build a wall it's
going to be built and we have to build
the wall and by the way the wall is
being built that's Biden is copying
Trump by building a wall but it's not
because grandpa had a come to Maga
Moment On the Border crisis Joe says he
had no choice I'll answer one question
on the border wall the Border wall the
money was appropriated for the border
wall I tried to get them to
reappropriate to redirect that money
they didn't they wouldn't and in the
meantime there's nothing under the law
other than they have to use the money
for what was appropriated I can't stop
that do you believe the border wall burs
no Biden is directly contradicting his
own DHS secretary who just claimed that
there was an acute and immediate need
for the wall and is now gutting all
environmental regulations to build one
it puts the White House in a tough spot
and has has him spinning faster than
Jesse after four tequila shots team
Biden can't piss off the farle with a
wall nor can they give the orange ombre
any credit does he have a disagreement
with his department of security
secretary I want to tell you what the
president said and what your colleague
asked him he said no he doesn't believe
that the speaking in direct
contradiction to what his own I hear you
I'm speaking for the president this is
something that we were required by law
and we are complying this is an
Administration that does believe in the
rule of law dhs's were required to
comply by the law we're complying by the
law DHS is complying by the law he said
there will not be another foot of Wall
constructed in my Administration so
something changed what you want us to
break the law is that what you want
Congress Congress appropriates the
funding we asked them to not use that
funding for that particular purpose they
denied it and now we're complying with
the law of course myoc is forced to put
out a statement moments ago claiming he
did not contradict Biden it's also
confusing and he says walls are not the
answer yet in the next paragraph he
admits they're still being forced to
build one meanwhile Trump is gorging on
Biden's border flipflop saying quote so
interesting to watch crooked Joe Biden
break every environmental law in the
book to prove that I was right will Joe
Biden apologize to me and America and
while Trump waits for Biden to bend the
knee liberal cities are crying Uncle
Chicago residents are fed up with
migrants flooding their City That's The
Simple Solution is no turn the around we
come in a community of black people
where we already get the low scraps and
then you want to take the little scrap
the resources that we have and put us at
the bottom of the barrel that's not fair
you cannot keep bringing immigrants in
the city does not have the money you
cannot track them you ain't tracking
them good at the police station you
don't know that name but you want to
spare them all over the city it is
unsanitary it's unsafe and it's just not
right M so Harold good to see you back
at the table you know how this happened
right you had to make the Democrats feel
the pain they had to share the burden so
it goes back to that move with the buses
it's the lesson for all issues you have
to share the suffering don't you agree I
agree it's good to be back table I I'm
I'm a Believer as I have on every issue
that being bold and even if you push the
envelope legally it's the right thing to
do there's no doubt uh that Greg Abbott
uh and I'll even give the Santa some
credit as they as they uh were able to
bust people or encourage people be Bust
or help bust them across the country it
made cities across the country
understand the kind of enormous
pressures that these cities on the
border are under uh I think the the the
White House has has had to do what the
White House had to do we can we can talk
about I love it when people come around
in my position and I'm not goingon to
I'm not going to bash them I'm G to
applaud them now I wish they had done it
sooner we've been saying this for a long
time around this table the wall as I've
said you've got to now reform the Asylum
process I do think the wall alone won't
work and I've I've said that on the show
but but we need uh we need an asylum
process that allows people to apply but
not stay in America while they do and if
they do if they're allowed to stay in
America the thresold has to be so high
you can't just come to the border and
say things are really bad at home and I
want to come here three we have to
invest in new technology and invest in
ways to help cities deal with this
enormous Challenge and four you know and
finally if if indeed we want aid for the
border which I think we do and we need
Aid in Ukraine tie it together and pass
it in a CR stop both sides politicizing
and complaining about this do what's
right for the border and don't let that
be an excuse not to do what's right
overseas and vice versa I applaud the
White House for doing this I don't quite
understand why you made if the reports
are right the mayorcas had to back off
the statement and saying that we're
going to build a wall but whatever the
case this is the right thing to do and I
would agree with you had it not been for
those governors sending those migrants
Greg you called it from the very
beginning we might not be in the place
we are today could have saved so much
time if you said Greg you're right Jesse
uh they had to hit rock bottom right and
the only reason why they had to hit rock
bottom is they are so allergic to any
words uttered by Trump they'd let the
they'd let the country suffer because
they can't admit that they were wrong
that's how insecure they are if you are
a politician like Donald Trump he was
always open-minded remember he never
wanted to commit to something because in
a negotiation you want to leave your
options open that's what Biden needs to
do and he could have easily said you
know what we're in a little trouble this
money's out there they tell me it's a
good idea to build it so we're going to
build it we're getting control and then
pivot away because then he looks like a
just a small man who can't admit a
mistake he's lying again because he said
he tried to convince Congress to
misappropriate the money they the
Democrats had the house in the senate
for two years they had it in 2021 2022
and so he couldn't convin Nancy and
Chuck to move the money somewhere else
that's a lie and then DHS they said this
was an acute need to do and they blew up
26 Federal Regulations to do it so that
doesn't sound like something that you
know it was and then they went to the
Supreme Court for stuff they ignored
enforcing the law with Hunter they could
have charged Hunter with tax felonies
they didn't do that he chooses what laws
he wants to enforce best part about this
thing Ducey goes well once they build it
are you just going to tear it down
because right that's legal to tear it
down now and he also drilled a hundred
holes in the wall so the analou can
migrate to Mexico so he could light it
on fire he could do what he wants but I
tell you what Greg it's going to cost us
like five times more than it should have
because he sold extra wall that was
gathering dust at a huge loss and I want
to hear what this new technology is how
many times have you heard oh there's all
this new technology that's going to stop
illegal immigration what is it what is
this new technology that's better than a
border wall they can't name it because
it doesn't exist the new technology is
making America
inhospitable that's what it is they're
doing a great job wire that you then cut
yes exactly that's new technology a wire
cutter Martha when you when you see that
America's in chaos in so many different
areas it has to do with what we're
seeing here which was a refusal to do
the right thing because it might align
you with your opposition it might align
you with Trump so whether it's crime or
riots or looting or immigration or
education you just go in the opposite
direction until you hit rock bottom it's
so stupid I I mean when you become
president every president your as a
leader one of your biggest most
important responsibilities is National
Security so if something's working just
pivot to other stuff leave that alone
you don't have to make a big deal out of
the fact that you're going to let that
stay that policy stay in place he had to
undo absolutely every single thing and
you know I was actually maybe I'm naive
I was surprised when I heard him
backpedal on this cuz I thought I was
going to hear something along the lines
of what Harold just mentioned that they
were pivoting that they were making a
turn in the policy and acknowledging the
problem there's nothing wrong as a
leader with saying I I I feel your pain
maybe it's taking us a little too long
to get here but I'm going to make up for
it right we're going to build this 20
miles obviously that you know it's 2,000
mil long we're going to build this 20
miles we think this is the most
important place to put it and we're
going to make sure that the people who
are yelling in Chicago I think those
might be the most powerful voices in
this story right now are the ones that
we just played because people in Chicago
and New York and all of these cities
which you point out you know they sent
these buses to they're like why do I
have to go to the back of the line right
and in politics you see sea changes and
I am very curious to see if we are on
the cusp of one of those right look what
happened in the midterms in New York and
California you had more conservatives
elected than anyone expected in a
midterm that really didn't go
conservatives way so watch these voices
like these voices in Chicago because I
and who's going to the South of the
Border now Eric Adams and the mayor of
of Chicago because they know that their
political situation is very precarious
they have to Pivot the president just
sits there and says well I'm not doing
anything different I'm only my hands are
tied on this I I I didn't have any
choice I have to build a wall I mean do
make sense to absolutely no one he said
about Afghanistan remember oh I had to
get out of there Trump made me leave at
that
timeline yes yeah I I I mean it's it's
Preposterous and I think most people
watching it just it just doesn't make
any sense to them no you know uh judge
what do you make of uh curing Jean
Pierre's uh complying with the law
excuse well you know I'm so I'm so
impressed that she's decided that that
both she and the president will follow
the law but I think the most the the
saddest part about all this is that uh
and and the obvious answer is that they
cannot admit that just as Martha the
point that Martha's making it's it's
just beyond the Republicans it's beyond
the Democrat Governor in Massachusetts
and the Democrat mayor in New York City
we're talking about the average American
uh in Chicago who says why do I have to
get to the back of the line you know you
don't even know their names and you're
spreading them all over our city I mean
that is the exact point we now have in
one year 151 known terrorists we have no
idea how many other terrorists have come
through and this excuse that you know we
have to build a wall that is an outright
lie they lie to us they Gaslight us all
the time and mayorcas can't even use the
word wall it's very clear we have an
acute need to construct a physical
barrier and roads in the vicinity of the
Border they can't use the word wall but
what I want to know is will they now
admit that they're racist and they're
xenophobes will they now admit that they
are hateful people for putting up this
wall because they've said that it's
immoral ineffective and expensive Elan
Omar said it was a monument uh wall to
racism and you know NBC said Trump's
border wall is never about security it's
a reminder of white supremacy and it's a
monument to white supremacy by Bloomberg
Trump's Wall of Shame is a white racist
hostility surging through the country I
mean all the takedown that they did and
now they're in a position not because
it's the right thing to do not because
it's a smart thing to do or because the
law requires it but because they know
they are losing these are political uh
operatives who only care about their
value in the political world they could
care less about any of us you know I
wonder if they use the word wall in
their personal daily life like honey I
think we should hang the family portrait
on the physical barrier in the living
hi everyone I'm Brian kilme I want you
to do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now